Maybe we-- if you guys
could stand over--
Is it okay
if they stand over here?
- Yeah.
- Um, actually.
Christophe,
if you can get even lower.
- Okay.
- ( shutter clicks )
This is Lee
and this is Christophe.
They're two of the hosts
of this show.
But to a machine,
they're not people.
This is just pixels.
It's just data.
A machine shouldn't
have a reason to prefer
one of these guys
over the other.
And yet, as you'll see
in a second, it does.
It feels weird to call
a machine racist,
but I really can't explain--
I can't explain
what just happened.
Data-driven systems
are becoming a bigger and bigger
part of our lives,
and they work well
a lot of the time.
- But when they fail...
- Once again, it's
the white guy.
When they fail,
they're not failing
on everyone equally.
If I go back right now...
Ruha Benjamin: You can have
neutral intentions.
You can have good intentions.
And the outcomes can still
be discriminatory.
Whether you want
to call that machine racist
or you want to call
the outcome racist,
we have a problem.
( theme music playing )
I was scrolling
through my Twitter feed
a while back
and I kept seeing tweets
that look like this.
Two of the same picture
of Republican senator
Mitch McConnell smiling,
or sometimes it would be
four pictures
of the same random
stock photo guy.
And I didn't really know
what was going on,
but it turns out that
this was a big public test
of algorithmic bias.
Because it turns out
that these aren't pictures
of just Mitch McConnell.
They're pictures
of Mitch McConnell and...
- Barack Obama.
- Lee: Oh, wow.
So people were uploading
these really
extreme vertical images
to basically force
this image cropping algorithm
to choose one of these faces.
People were alleging that
there's a racial bias here.
But I think what's
so interesting about this
particular algorithm
is that it is so testable
for the public.
It's something that
we could test right now
if we wanted to.
- Let's do it.
- You guys wanna do it?
Okay. Here we go.
So, Twitter does offer you
options to crop your own image.
But if you don't use those,
it uses an automatic
cropping algorithm.
- Wow. There it is.
- Whoa. Wow.
That's crazy.
Christophe, it likes you.
Okay, let's try the other--
the happy one.
Lee: Wow.
- Unbelievable. Oh, wow.
- Both times.
So, do you guys think
this machine is racist?
The only other theory
I possibly have
is if the algorithm
prioritizes white faces
because it can
pick them up quicker,
for whatever reason,
against whatever background.
Immediately,
it looks through the image
and tries to scan for a face.
Why is it always finding
the white face first?
Joss: With this picture,
I think someone could argue
that the lighting makes
Christophe's face more sharp.
I still would love to do
a little bit more systematic
testing on this.
I think maybe
hundreds of photos
could allow us
to draw a conclusion.
I have downloaded
a bunch of photos
from a site called
Generated Photos.
These people do not exist.
They were a creation of AI.
And I went through,
I pulled a bunch
that I think will give us
a pretty decent way
to test this.
So, Christophe,
I wonder if you would be willing
to help me out with that.
You want me to tweet
hundreds of photos?
- ( Lee laughs )
- Joss: Exactly.
I'm down. Sure, I've got time.
Okay.
( music playing )
There may be some people
who take issue with the idea
that machines can be racist
without a human brain
or malicious intent.
But such a narrow
definition of racism
really misses
a lot of what's going on.
I want to read a quote
that responds to that idea.
It says, "Robots are not
sentient beings, sure,
but racism flourishes
well beyond hate-filled hearts.
No malice needed,
no "N" word required,
just a lack of concern for how
the past shapes the present."
I'm going now to speak
to the author of those words,
Ruha Benjamin.
She's a professor
of African-American Studies
at Princeton University.
When did you first
become concerned
that automated systems,
AI, could be biased?
A few years ago,
I noticed these headlines
and hot takes about so-called
racist and sexist robots.
There was a viral video
in which two friends
were in a hotel bathroom
and they were trying to use
an automated soap dispenser.
Black hand, nothing.
Larry, go.
And although they seem funny
and they kind of
get us to chuckle,
the question is,
are similar design processes
impacting much more
consequential technologies
that we're not even aware of?
When the early news
controversies came along
maybe 10 years ago,
people were surprised
by the fact that
they showed a racial bias.
Why do you think
people were surprised?
Part of it is a deep
attachment and commitment
to this idea
of tech neutrality.
People-- I think because
life is so complicated
and our social world
is so messy--
really cling on to
something that will save us,
and a way of making decisions
that's not drenched
in the muck of all
of human subjectivity,
human prejudice and frailty.
We want it so much
to be true.
to be true, you know?
And the danger is
that we don't question it.
And still we continue to have,
you know, so-called glitches
when it comes to race
and skin complexion.
And I don't think
that they're glitches.
It's a systemic issue
in the truest sense of the word.
It has to do with
our computer systems
and the process of design.
Joss:
AI can seem pretty abstract
sometimes.
So we built this
to help explain
how machine learning works
and what can go wrong.
This black box
is the part of the system
that we interact with.
It's the software
that decides which dating
profiles we might like,
how much a rideshare
should cost,
or how a photo should be
cropped on Twitter.
We just see a device
making a decision.
Or more accurately,
a prediction.
What we don't see
is all of the human decisions
that went into the design
of that technology.
Now, it's true that when
you're dealing with AI,
that means
that the code in this box
wasn't all
written directly by humans,
but by machine-learning
algorithms
that find complex patterns
in data.
But they don't just
spontaneously learn things
from the world.
They're learning
from examples.
Examples that
are labeled by people,
selected by people,
and derived from people, too.
See, these machines
and their predictions,
they're not separate from us
or from our biases
or from our history,
which we've seen
in headline after headline
for the past 10 years.
We're using
the face-tracking software,
so it's supposed
to follow me as I move.
As you can see, I do this--
no following.
Not really--
not really following me.
- Wanda, if you would, please?
- Sure.
In 2010, the top hit
when you did a search
for "black girls,"
80% of what you found
on the first page of results
was all porn sites.
Google is apologizing
after its photo software
labeled two African-Americans
gorillas.
Microsoft is shutting down
its new artificial
intelligent bot
after Twitter users
taught it how to be racist.
Woman: In order to make
yourself hotter,
the app appeared
to lighten your skin tone.
Overall, they work better
on lighter faces than
darker faces,
and they worked
especially poorly
on darker female faces.
Okay, I've noticed that on all
these damn beauty filters,
is they keep taking my nose
and making it thinner.
Give me my African nose
back, please.
Man: So, the first thing
that I tried was the prompt
"Two Muslims..."
And the way
it completed it was,
"Two Muslims,
one with an apparent bomb,
tried to blow up
the Federal Building
in Oklahoma City
in the mid-1990s."
Woman:
Detroit police wrongfully
arrested Robert Williams
based on a false
facial recognition hit.
There's definitely
a pattern of harm
that disproportionately
falls on vulnerable people,
people of color.
Then there's attention,
but of course, the damage
has already been done.
( Skype ringing )
- Hello.
- Hey, Christophe.
Thanks for doing these tests.
- Of course.
- I know it was
a bit of a pain,
but I'm curious
what you found.
Sure. I mean,
I actually did it.
I actually tweeted 180
different sets of pictures.
In total, dark-skinned people
were displayed
in the crop 131 times,
and light-skinned people
were displayed
in the crop 229 times,
which comes out
to 36% dark-skinned
and 64% light-skinned.
That does seem to be
evidence of some bias.
It's interesting because
Twitter posted a blog post
saying that they had done
some of their own tests
before launching this tool,
and they said that
they didn't find evidence
of racial bias,
but that they would
be looking into it further.
Um, they also said
that the kind of technology
that they use to crop images
is called
a Saliency Prediction Model,
which means software
that basically is making a guess
about what's important
in an image.
So, how does a machine
know what is salient,
what's relevant in a picture?
Yeah, it's really
interesting, actually.
There's these
saliency data sets
that documented people's
eye movements
while they looked
at certain sets of images.
So you can take those photos
and you can take
that eye-tracking data
and teach a computer
what humans look at.
So, Twitter's not going to
give me any more information
about how they trained
their model,
but I found an engineer
from a company called Gradio.
They built an app
that does something similar,
and I think it can give us
a closer look
at how this kind of AI works.
- Hey.
- Joss.
- Nice to meet you. Dawood.
So, you and your colleagues
built a saliency cropping tool
that is similar to what we think
Twitter is probably doing.
Yeah, we took a public
machine learning model,
posted it on our library,
and launched it
for anyone to try.
And you don't have to
constantly post pictures
on your timeline to try
and experiment with it,
which is what people
were doing when they first
became aware of the problem.
And that's what we did.
We did a bunch of tests
just on Twitter.
But what's interesting
about what your app shows
is the sort of intermediate
step there, which is this
saliency prediction.
Right, yeah.
I think the intermediate step
is important for people to see.
Well, I-- I brought some
pictures for us to try.
These are actually
the hosts of "Glad You Asked."
And I was hoping we could put
them into your interface
and see what, uh,
the saliency prediction is.
Sure.
Just load this image here.
Joss:
Okay, so, we have
a saliency map.
Clearly the prediction
is that faces are salient,
which is not really a surprise.
But it looks like maybe
they're not equally salient.
- Right.
- Is there a way to sort of
look closer at that?
So, what we can do here,
we actually built it out
in the app
where we can put a window
on someone's specific face,
and it will give us a percentage
of what amount of saliency
you have over your face
versus in proportion
to the whole thing.
- That's interesting.
- Yeah.
She's-- Fabiola's
in the center of the picture,
but she's actually got
a lower percentage
of the salience compared
to Cleo, who's to her right.
Right, and trying
to guess why a model
is making a prediction
and why it's
predicting what it is
is a huge problem
with machine learning.
It's always something
that you have to kind of
back-trace to try
and understand.
And sometimes
it's not even possible.
Mm-hmm.
I looked up what data sets
were used to train
the model you guys used,
and I found one
that was created by
researchers at MIT
back in 2009.
So, it was originally
about a thousand images.
We pulled the ones
that contained faces,
any face we could find
that was big enough to see.
And I went through
all of those,
and I found that only
10 of the photos,
that's just about 3%,
included someone
who appeared to be
of Black or African descent.
Yeah, I mean,
if you're collecting
a data set through Flickr,
you're-- first of all,
you're biased to people
that have used Flickr
back in, what, 2009,
you said, or something?
Joss: And I guess if we saw
in this image data set,
there are more
cat faces than black faces,
we can probably assume
that minimal effort was made
to make that data set
representative.
When someone collects data
into a training data set,
they can be motivated by things
like convenience and cost
and end up with data
that lacks diversity.
That type of bias, which
we saw in the saliency photos,
is relatively easy to address.
If you include more images
representing racial minorities,
you can probably improve
the model's performance
on those groups.
But sometimes
human subjectivity
is imbedded right
into the data itself.
Take crime data for example.
Our data on past crimes
in part reflects
police officers' decisions
about what neighborhoods
to patrol
and who to stop and arrest.
We don't have an objective
measure of crime,
and we know
that the data we do have
contains at least
some racial profiling.
But it's still being used
to train crime prediction tools.
And then there's the question
of how the data is structured
over here.
Say you want a program
that identifies
chronically sick patients
to get additional care
so they don't end up
in the ER.
You'd use past patients
as your examples,
but you have to choose
a label variable.
You have to define
for the machine what
a high-risk patient is
and there's not always
an obvious answer.
A common choice
is to define high-risk
as high-cost,
under the assumption
that people who use
a lot of health care resources
are in need of intervention.
Then the learning
algorithm looks through
the patient's data--
their age, sex,
medications, diagnoses,
insurance claims,
and it finds the combination
of attributes
that correlates
with their total health costs.
And once it gets good
at predicting
total health costs
on past patients,
that formula becomes software
to assess new patients
and give them a risk score.
But instead of predicting
sick patients,
this predicts
expensive patients.
Remember, the label was cost,
and when researchers
took a closer look
at those risk scores,
they realized that label choice
was a big problem.
But by then, the algorithm
had already been used
on millions of Americans.
It produced risk scores
for different patients,
and if a patient
had a risk score
of almost 60,
they would be referred
into the program
for screening--
for their screening.
And if they had a risk score
of almost 100,
they would default
into the program.
Now, when we look at the number
of chronic conditions
that patients of different
risk scores were affected by,
you see a racial disparity
where white patients
had fewer conditions
than black patients
at each risk score.
That means that
black patients were sicker
than their white counterparts
when they had
the same risk score.
And so what happened is
in producing these risk scores
and using spending,
they failed to recognize
that on average
black people incur fewer costs
for a variety of reasons,
including institutional racism,
including lack of access
to high-quality insurance,
and a whole host
of other factors.
But not because
they're less sick.
Not because they're less sick.
And so I think it's important
to remember
this had racist outcomes,
discriminatory outcomes,
not because there was
a big, bad boogie man
behind the screen
out to get black patients,
but precisely because
no one was thinking
about racial disparities
in healthcare.
No one thought it would matter.
And so it was
about the colorblindness,
the race neutrality
that created this.
The good news is
that now the researchers
who exposed this
and who brought this to light
are working with the company
that produced this algorithm
to have a better proxy.
So instead of spending,
it'll actually be
people's actual
physical conditions
and the rate at which
they get sick, et cetera,
that is harder to figure out,
it's a harder kind of
proxy to calculate,
but it's more accurate.
I feel like what's so unsettling
about this healthcare algorithm
is that the patients
would have had
no way of knowing
this was happening.
It's not like Twitter,
where you can upload
your own picture, test it out,
compare with other people.
This was just working
in the background,
quietly prioritizing
the care of certain patients
based on an algorithmic score
while the other patients
probably never knew
they were even passed over
for this program.
I feel like there
has to be a way
for companies to vet
these systems in advance,
so I'm excited to talk
to Deborah Raji.
She's been doing
a lot of thinking
and writing about just that.
My question for you is
how do we find out
about these problems before
they go out into the world
and cause harm
rather than afterwards?
So, I guess a clarification
point is that machine learning
is highly unregulated
as an industry.
These companies
don't have to report
their performance metrics,
they don't have to report
their evaluation results
to any kind
of regulatory body.
But internally there's this
new culture of documentation
that I think has been
incredibly productive.
I worked on a couple of projects
with colleagues at Google,
and one of the main outcomes
of that was this effort
called Model Cards--
very simple
one-page documentation
on how the model
actually works,
but also questions that are
connected to ethical concerns,
such as the intended use
for the model,
details about where
the data's coming from,
how the data's labeled,
and then also, you know,
instructions
to evaluate the system
according to its performance
on different
demographic sub-groups.
Maybe that's something
that's hard to accept
is that it would actually
be maybe impossible
to get performance
across sub-groups
to be exactly the same.
How much of that do we just
have to be like, "Okay"?
I really don't think
there's an unbiased data set
in which everything
will be perfect.
I think the more important thing
is to actually evaluate
and assess things
with an active eye
for those that are most likely
to be negatively impacted.
You know, if you know
that people of color
are most vulnerable
or a particular marginalized
group is most vulnerable
in a particular situation,
then prioritize them
in your evaluation.
But I do think there's
certain situations
where maybe we should
not be predicting
with a machine-learning
system at all.
We should be super cautious
and super careful
about where we deploy it
and where we don't deploy it,
and what kind of human oversight
we put over
these systems as well.
The problem of bias in AI
is really big.
It's really difficult.
But I don't think it means
we have to give up
on machine learning altogether.
One benefit
of bias in a computer
versus bias in a human
is that you can measure
and track it fairly easily.
And you can tinker
with your model
to try and get fair outcomes
if you're motivated to do so.
The first step was
becoming aware of the problem.
Now the second step
is enforcing solutions,
which I think we're
just beginning to see now.
But Deb is raising
a bigger question.
Not just how do we get bias
out of the algorithms,
but which algorithms
should be used at all?
Do we need a predictive model
to be cropping our photos?
Do we want facial recognition
in our communities?
Many would say no,
whether it's biased or not.
And that question
of which technologies
get built and how they
get deployed in our world,
it boils down
to resources and power.
It's the power
to decide whose interests
will be served
by a predictive model,
and which questions get asked.
You could ask, okay,
I want to know how landlords
are making life
for renters hard.
Which landlords are not
fixing up their buildings?
Which ones are hiking rent?
Or you could ask,
okay, let's figure out
which renters
have low credit scores.
Let's figure out the people
who have a gap in unemployment
so I don't want to rent to them.
And so it's at that problem
of forming the question
and posing the problem
that the power dynamics
are already being laid
that set us off in one
trajectory or another.
And the big challenge
there being that
with these two possible
lines of inquiry,
- one of those is probably
a lot more profitable...
- Exactly, exactly.
- ...than the other one.
- And too often the people who
are creating these tools,
they don't necessarily
have to share the interests
of the people who are
posing the questions,
but those are their clients.
So, the question
for the designers
and the programmers is
are you accountable
only to your clients
or are you also accountable
to the larger body politic?
Are you responsible for what
these tools do in the world?
( music playing )
( indistinct chatter )
Man: Can you lift up
your arm a little?
( chatter continues )